okay Republican National Committee uh
chair Ronna McDaniel appeared this
morning on Fox and Friends really weird
interview it did not go well at all
couple topics were mentioned number one
a new ad put out by the RNC with AI
generated footage
and secondly the topic of debates and
Donald Trump we'll do the first thing
first and the second thing second
although we could reverse that order but
let's not do it either way you wouldn't
really know okay no but we'll start with
the AI deep fake thing so the RNC put
out an ad
painting a picture with AI video of a
dystopian America under Biden the
footage is fake it was created by AI
it's not footage of anything that
actually took place so
Ronald McDaniel says it is not a deep
fake but it it's literally fake now deep
fake AI generated footage is fake
footage deep fake footages fake footage
we're just talking semantics here and
she with a straight face says it's AI
generated but it's not a deep fake maybe
she just doesn't even know what these
terms mean all right so let's talk about
what you guys did you immediately
responded to his rollout saying he's
going to run again he kind of said that
let me finish the job you guys rolled
this out and it's AI generated here's a
portion
border agents were overrun by a surge of
80 000 illegals yesterday evening
officials closed the city of San
Francisco
signing the escalating crime and
Fentanyl crisis so Rana essentially
saying that will happen if he gets four
more years uh what Pro can you bring us
the the mindset going into that ad
it is AI generated so we're sharing that
that up front ethically so it's not a
deep fake every single image was AI but
we are painting a picture of a future
vitamin so it's quite literally fake now
I guess what she she seems to think that
if you admit that it's fake then it's
not a deep fake I guess like if you
would if you're like hey I'm going to
show you something fake then it's a
shallow fake or something but then if
she were to lie about it then it would
be a deep fake of course it seems that
she doesn't even really know what these
terms mean and it's it's worth looking
at the ad
because one of the unfortunate realities
of Technology advancing the way it's
advancing you know the AI generated
Trump arrest pictures which were not
real and all of these things is that the
worst instincts of the worst people
are now much more easily translatable
into a finished product that might pass
muster and when you look at the video
from that AI attack ad that the RNC put
out
you taken out of context you would have
no idea that it's fake and this is going
to be I mean we've already looked at the
the fake videos of elected officials
appearing to say things that they didn't
say this is going to be a new layer now
in political dishonesty
they showed it but do you have video of
it used to be a pretty good way of
determining whether a claim might be
true at least or is true now hey yeah I
have video of it it increasingly isn't
even going to be the evidence we need to
determine whether something did or
didn't really happen so arguably
dangerous stuff I don't believe that we
can stop it I think we need to figure
out how to work with it then the topic
of debates came up as we talked about
earlier yesterday Donald Trump flipped
out and said nobody consulted me about
doing the first debate you know whatever
in August or whatever and sort of
suggesting he might not go and Steve
Bannon saying Trump Should Skip the all
the debates all together here's Ronna
McDaniel saying Trump doesn't
historically shy away from debates and
Brian kilometer is like well actually he
did Skip one of our debates and she's
like okay fine he did Skip One and the
entire story here for me is Ronald
McDaniel continues to lose control of
the monster that the Republican party
has created
Democrats don't want a debate with Joe
on the stage I saw yesterday that Donald
Trump uh on true social said I see that
everybody is talking about the
Republican debates but nobody got my
approval or the approval of the campaign
uh Trump campaign before announcing them
when you're leading by seemingly
insurmountable numbers and you have
hostile networks angry with Trump trump
and mega hating anchors asking the
questions why subject yourself to being
liable and abused so did you talk to him
about the debates is he in or is this
just what he does he he did this in
2016. working the refs
I talked to president Trump all the time
and we've talked to all the potential
candidates we've let them know the
schedule we've announced the debates the
first debate's going to be with Fox
Milwaukee but every campaign and every
candidate is going to have to make a
decision do I want to participate he's
going to have to make that decision I
think he'll do it and president Trump
never shies away from a debate uh
he skipped hours he skipped hours in
2016.
he did he skipped one but you know he
was on the center of the debate stage in
2016 and he never left it so we'll see
what happens but we are talking to the
campaigns and the candidates I talked to
president Trump and and Mike Pence and
and Nikki Haley were talking to all of
them all the time and we'll see what
happens what does it mean that she
talked to Mike Pence by the way Mike
Pence is Mike Pence running I don't even
know what that but that's kind of a
weird thing to interject there that that
is interesting uh so the debate thing is
going to be interesting as I said
earlier if you're Trump depending on
whether DeSantis is or isn't running the
calculation as to whether you should or
shouldn't participate in debates is a
different one now 20 years ago the idea
that a presidential candidate a serious
presidential candidate polling well
would not participate in debates would
be almost unheard of but this is a
Republican party who makes excuses for
whoever it is that they want to see
elected
um when it came to Trump's taxes there
were excuses when it came to Trump's a
personal misdeeds there were excuses and
when it comes to Trump not debating
there will certainly be excuses and
there were indeed as well for the debate
that Trump skipped uh previously so this
is where we are at this point in time
Ronald McDaniel has completely lost
control of the party and one of the
things about Trump talks to me regularly
is that Trump doesn't care one way or
the other
um what Ronald McDaniel wants Trump sees
the RNC the way he sees everyone in his
life someone that I might be able to use
to advance what's best for me or maybe
not in which case I'll just bail and say
they were disloyal and unfair and we
will move on ultimately I think that
Trump is more likely to debate than not
to debate taking into consideration
everything that we know right now but of
course the first debate is almost four
months away and a lot can happen between
now and then so we will follow it